what could I do to destroy my business  that if I did this it would all stop for  example if I stopped creating free  content that was better than everyone  else in the marketplace I would  eventually stop getting new customers if  I hired a team of people that were not  good then I would lose my reputation if  I select customers that are not going to  be likely to be successful then I'm not  going to create the client outcomes and  my reputation will suffer as a result  these anchors will change over time but  the easiest way to discover them is not  to think what should I do to be  successful but how few things that have  the biggest leverage could I do to  destroy my business reverse those and  you'll find your competitive advantage